Easter eggs related to Star Wars in non-Star
Wars movie franchises are very common.
Hollywood seems to love giving a nod to the
iconic sci-fi franchise and Disney movies
are no exception to that rule - especially
now that Star Wars is owned and distributed
by the mass media and entertainment conglomerate.
Whether it be the classic animated movies
we all know and love, the Marvel Studios movies
that Disney now distributes, or otherwise,
Disney movies are teaming with Star Wars Easter
eggs - and that's what this video is all about.
So sit back, enjoy, and make sure you subscribe
to ScreenRant to regularly see great videos
like this one.
Here are ten Star Wars Easter eggs you may
have missed in other Disney movies.
Captain America: Civil War
2016's Captain America: Civil War saw a very
explicit reference to 1980's The Empire Strikes
Back, with the movie being mentioned out loud
in the epic airport battle between Team Captain
America and Team Iron Man.
It happens after Scott Lang has grown to become
Giant-Man and Team Iron Man are struggling
to take him down.
Tom Holland's Spider-Man refers to the scene
in The Empire Strikes Back "on the snow planet,
with the walking thingies" and proceeds to
wrap his webbing around the huge superhero's
legs - in the same way the AT-AT's legs were
wrapped up - allowing Iron Man and War Machine
to take him down with relative ease.
Up
There's a very cool Star Wars Easter egg in
the final credit sequence of 2009's Up, so
if you stuck around for them, you may well
have seen it.
In the middle of the credits, there's an image
of the movie's two main protagonists, Carl
and Russell, exiting a screening of the original
Star Wars at a movie theatre.
Russell clearly seems to have enjoyed the
movie and is looking categorically buoyant
as he points to the movie's title on the movie
theatre's sign, whereas Carl looks a lot less
impressed with it!
The Sorcerer's Apprentice
In 2010's The Sorcerer's Apprentice, there's
a scene in which Alfred Molina's Maxim Horvath
- an evil sorcerer and the nemesis of Nicolas
Cage's Balthazar - tries to get past the New
York University administrator, who is asking
him to show ID, by using magic to persuade
him.
Because of the fact that his actions and tone
of voice are very reminiscent of Obi-Wan Kenobi's
in the original Star Wars movie, Toby Kebbell's
Drake responds to the situation by saying
"These are not the droids you're looking for."
Tinker Bell and the Great Fairy Rescue
Arguably the most unlikely movie on this list
to expect a Star Wars reference to appear,
2010's sequel to both 2008's Tinker Bell and
2009's Tinker Bell and the Lost Treasure,
Tinker Bell and the Great Fairy Rescue does
indeed include a neat little Star Wars Easter
egg.
It’s an extremely subtle Easter egg as well.
When he's making a boat for the fairies, Bobble
- voiced by Rob Paulsen - quotes Han Solo
from The Empire Strikes Back by saying “This
one goes there, that one goes there, right?”
Chicken Little
2005's Chicken Little also has a quote subtly
and directly lifted from a Star Wars movie.
In 1977's Star Wars, the line "Stay on target,
stay on target!" is said when the X-Wing pilots
are attempting to blow up the Death Star.
In Chicken Little, "Ace" - the movie version
of the titular character within the movie
- repeats this line while navigating his ship
through space to defeat some aliens.
Incidentally, there also happens to be a reference
to Darth Vader being Luke's father in the
movie.
Wreck-It Ralph
2012's Wreck-It Ralph has a few references
to, and Easter eggs relating to, the Star
Wars movies - and we're going to tell you
about a couple of them here.
For starters, there's a scene in which Ralph
is breathing through a straw in a chocolate
lake.
The breathing you can hear as a result is
actually Darth Vader's breathing noise from
the Star Wars movies.
Moreover, there is a Star Wars arcade game
that can clearly be seen in a wide view of
Litwak's Arcade in the movie.
The Marvel Cinematic Universe
We now come to a more general entry, as we
embrace the Marvel Cinematic Universe's ongoing
dedication to Star Wars homages.
In pretty much every MCU Phase 2 movie, the
franchise paid tribute to 1980's The Empire
Strikes Back, as characters lost their hands
or arms like Luke Skywalker did when Darth
Vader severed his hand.
Examples include Darren Cross in Ant-Man,
Bucky Barnes in Captain America: The Winter
Soldier, Aldrich Killian in Iron Man 3, Thor
in Thor: The Dark World, Groot in Guardians
of the Galaxy, and Ulysses Klaue in Avengers:
Age of Ultron.
Tomorrowland
There are countless Star Wars Easter eggs
in Tomorrowland - the 2015 movie that takes
inspiration from a number of Disney theme
parks and themed lands within Disney's theme
parks around the world.
One of these Easter eggs is, like the recurring
MCU Easter egg, a character getting his hand
cut off by George Clooney's character Frank.
But others include the Star Wars theme music
being played and a number of Star Wars-themed
items in the "Blast From the Past" store in
the movie (including lightsabers, a Death
Star toy and a Stormtrooper helmet), as well
as Kathryn Hahn's Ursula Gernsback having
hair like Prince Leia.
The Toy Story Movies
There are literally loads of Star Wars Easter
eggs and references in the Toy Story movies
- and we'd be going all day if we mentioned
them all - so we'll just give you one from
each of Toy Story 1, 2 and 3.
In 1995's Toy Story, when Buzz sees the Buzz
Lightyear commercial on TV, the sound when
he "shoots" a laser is the TIE fighter's cannon
sound.
In 1999's Toy Story 2, when a camera comes
out through a trap door in a wall, it's a
nod to Jabba the Hutt's palace's camera at
the main entrance.
And finally, in Toy Story 3, when Big Baby
throws Lotso the Bear into a dumpster, it's
a reference to Darth Vader throwing Emperor
Palpatine into the reactor.
Finding Dory
Whether or not you consider this to be an
Easter egg is open to your own interpretation,
but 2016's Finding Dory certainly has something
in common with 2015's with Star Wars: The
Force Awakens.
The common ground comes in the form of Finding
Dory's Hank, a cranky East Pacific red octopus
who lost a tentacle, and the Rathtar in The
Force Awakens.
Some of the technical ideas that shaped Hank’s
existence were indeed first utilised on the
tentacle predator in Episode VII - so their
rendering is pretty similar.
Thanks for watching our video about ten Star
Wars Easter eggs you may have missed in other
Disney movies?
Can you think of any other Disney movies with
Star Wars Easter eggs in them?
Have your say in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.